you
child of light is a modern fairytale the
main character of the game is named oh
haha she's the young daughter of a Duke
that wakes one morning in the magical
kingdom of Lemuria and at first she
believes she's in a dream and then she's
struggling and get home to her father to
do that she'll learn quickly that [ __ ]
needs to embark on a quest where she
needs to recover the power of the Sun
the moon and the star in order to defeat
the queen of the night and along her
journey she starts to discover the
secrets of this place and all of a
sudden she decides that she's gonna do
something different her destiny shifts
aurora is mischievous she's a little bit
green behind the ears because she hasn't
really been out of her castle much and
her father has taken care of her since
her mother died so you get this
wonderful mix of being precocious and at
the same time learning about the world
anew oh ho Ha Bastion petit ET avec
under Sharia booski flow todo del ni con
ojos para la nabisco personnel p a town
called is on Angela Mon Amiral engines
casio zygerria drive our kids to get
John does feel like that their shop it's
the type of a combative character that i
really like that's ready to explore it
ready to do anything and she really
reminds me of my kid as she's going to
meet people in our quest she's going to
start to grow and to see that if you
have the power to help people then it's
important to act for the greater good
it's a transformative journey from
childhood to adulthood and for me that's
the true spirit of fairy tales
if I can see on the concave alive I
looky commercial market econ econ for
something an Italian penis on phone just
one of para la casa princesa
distribution proven to sweeten this new
girl everybody's on Form don't see
Claire quality or anything on graham
Brown whatever you do the writing and
child of light is entirely in rhyme it's
an epic valid based on works such as
Rime of the Ancient Mariner and so I had
to really treat almost every stanza as a
puzzle the intricate use of text as an
expressive medium is really central to
child of light for the voice of the
narrator we went with Catalan de vivre
mouse she's an actress from Montreal she
sounds like the perfect mother that how
she would tell a story to our children
and for me was really important to
capture that vibe and set the tone for
the fairytale adventure it we're living
till one night there was no trace the
Queen had vanished and with her the
light this is a game in which you level
up Aurora at first is unformed in the
player forms Aurora through the process
of leveling and so this game had to be
about that process of forming for me it
had to be a coming-of-age story
you